ANDY GRANOWITZ: Hi.
Andy Granowitz here, developer
advocate for Google Analytics.
Today I'm going to talk a
little about setting up Google
Analytics for the first time.
Google Analytics is known for
being straightforward to deploy
on your website or app.
And although this is true,
there are a few important things
to consider when
you install Google
Analytics for the
first time to make
sure you get the most out
of the powerful features
that Google Analytics offers.
The most basic
measurement track--
measurement is going to
be pageview or screen view
tracking on web and
app, respectively.
For most websites, setting
up pageview tracking
is straightforward.
Add the Google Analytics
JavaScript snippet
on every page, and
Google Analytics
will count each time
the page is loaded.
This is a little bit more
involved on mobile apps.
But once you set up
screen view tracking
using iOS or Android SDK,
the results are very similar.
Google Analytics will measure
a lot by default, even
with this basic setup.
For example, with just page
or screen view tracking,
Google Analytics
will automatically
allow you to analyze the
session duration, time
on specific pages or screens;
geo-information, like city
and state; technology data,
like mobile device or browser;
user flow between
pages or screens;
and where users are coming
from, like search engines,
social networks, referrals
from other sites, and so on.
So there's a lot that's
captured automatically.
But with some customization,
Google Analytics
can capture user
interactions that
are unique to your site
or app and that are really
important to your business.
Google Analytics offers many
different customizations
for many different
use cases ranging
from measuring e-commerce to
how long resources take to load,
but there are
three that I'd like
to highlight when
first getting set up--
events, custom dimensions,
and campaign tagging.
Events are used to measure
interactions within a given
page, in other words,
anything that is not
a page load or a new screen.
But keep in mind that you don't
need to measure everything.
Think about what are the most
important user interactions
and plan to measure those.
This will prevent data
overload when doing analysis.
Custom dimensions.
As we discussed,
Google Analytics
captures a lot of
data by default.
But often, the most
important information
is very specific
to your business,
making it difficult
for Google Analytics
to measure without a
little help from you.
With custom dimensions,
you can send custom data
to Google Analytics,
which will automatically
get correlated with
all of the other data
that Google Analytics collects.
For example, when signing
up for your newsletter,
if the user has the option
to identify their industry,
you may want to pass this
information as a custom
dimension.
Another example might be when a
user signs up for your service,
whether they signed up
for the 30-day trial,
a standard membership,
or a premium membership.
The final customization
that I'd like to talk about
is campaign tagging.
Google Analytics looks
at the HTTP refer
and does its best
to figure out where
your traffic is coming from.
But when you run custom
campaigns, like through an ad
network, or if you're
doing some email marketing,
or, really, any
other medium, you
can use the Google
Analytics URL Builder
to add query parameters
to the URL you're
promoting to your users.
When users click on that link,
the parameters you've added
are automatically recognized
by Google Analytics.
So in your reports, you'll
be able to find out exactly
which campaigns brought
users to your site or app
and what they ultimately did.
One special case.
If you use AdWords,
I strongly recommend
that you link Google Analytics
and AdWords accounts.
By doing so, your AdWords
campaigns will automatically
get tagged with
campaign parameters,
and a lot of other
valuable data will
be imported into your
Google Analytics account.
In addition to this deep
integration with AdWords,
Google Analytics
can also integrate
with other Google products, such
as AdSense, Webmaster Tools,
AdMob, and more.
Be sure to find out
if there's an easy way
to connect Google
Analytics and whatever
technologies you are using,
whether they are Google or not.
For more information on these
customizations and more,
check out the links
below or go to
developers.google.com/analytics.